all right well let's talk about
something else something makes me feel
good
so uh i'm i'm browsing the old reddit
and i come across this post from a
subreddit called buy buy job
and i'm like gee i wonder what this is
all about
well basically it's supposed to be a
subreddit where people who do bad things
and get fired get made fun of
all right kind of a negative thing you
know reddit loves bullies so as long as
it's okay with the establishment
bullying so i notice a whole lot of
these things are people who are like the
vaccine mandate is wrong i will not
abide by this and they're being mocked
and made fun of so i'm like i'm going to
scroll through this subreddit bye bye
job and wow the top post here my wife
was a doctor has been a doctor for 30
years kitty transplant specialist
emergency specialist hospitalist didn't
lose a cove patient patient has natural
immunity and will tomorrow see her last
day because science we stand to lose
everything she has ever worked for wow
remember when doctors were heroes they
put a clown face they put a clown face
no jab no job we will miss you hahaha
vaccine bad
then we have this one then we have this
one it's basically hero fiber i saw this
and they're like oh they also have the
sohcahtoa lady that was actually really
funny but i saw this and they're making
fun of all of these people who are like
i am standing up for what i believe in
and i'm just like
this is actually a white pill you know
it's like an optimistic
light
all of these posts it's hard to sing
it's hard to believe when i see all of
these posts of people saying i will not
comply i'm like wow yeah maybe more
people than we realize look at orange
county battalion chief fired after he
didn't issue reprimands over vaccine
mandate raleigh's restaurant ordered to
remain closed over coveted
non-compliance
what is this one another youtube channel
got a strike or whatever i guess i don't
know ge aviation employees walk out over
vaccine mandate according to an employee
participating in the protest up to 75 of
staff did not show up for work at the
durham north carolina peebles ohio and
lafayette indiana locations wow that's
amazing that's great someone gets banned
or whatever and then nearly 1 900
washington state employees quit fired
over vaccine mandate assisted living
anti-vax nurse fired for vaccine refusal
actor chad john kimball claims he lost
come from a way job over religion it's a
and they said they put vaccine bad on it
all of these posts i'm like yo if you
want to see hope for humanity go to r
bye bye job and cheer for these people
who are saying bye-bye job because
they're standing up for what they
believe in yeah i wonder how much of
that southwest thing triggered a lot of
that and with the in and out thing
happening and now you're seeing i don't
know how these are dated but i mean i
feel like something's happening right
now where you're actually able to see
that if you do actually stand up for
yourself things happen but it's got to
be a unified thing and that's always
been the problem is getting everybody to
on board but yeah i don't know i mean
this isn't this isn't organized yeah i
mean some of it is clearly when 75 of
workers don't show up that's what i mean
though but the southwest thing i talked
to a pilot and he said that it's
basically just everybody realizing if
i'm gonna get fired i'm gonna use my
sick time
it's like i might as well use my
vacation days while i still can
well it's illegal for them to officially
protest but it's also important to note
here that southwest lost an estimated 75
million dollars in the four days where
this alleged freedom flew was going
around and whether it's sick leave or
paid leave
you know it does show the disruptions
that these mandates are causing that are
dividing people to a point where a lot
of people are not working now you add
that to the supply chain shortages
you're asking for a disaster to happen
here because we're not going to have
enough workers for a lot of very
important tasks that need to be done
there and seeing all these people resist
and you know some people are deciding to
make fun of them but you made a good
point here there's a lot of them just
amazing and i've been talking about this
for a while the the perception of what
we see on on the mainstream media on big
tech social media is a perception that
obviously is ignoring
huge protests that are happening not
just all across the united states but
all over the world there's major huge
demonstrations with thousands of people
tens of thousands even in some instances
hundreds of thousands of people hitting
the streets saying enough is enough i am
not complying with your nonsense i'm not
going to be asking for permission for
from the government to go to the grocery
store i'm not going to do that i also
want to point out on this subreddit they
have uh real bryson gray he got a strike
on youtube for his song called let's go
brandon yes wow for uh i guess i said
medical misinformation
vaccine bad there was also some reports
about tick tock potentially going after
him as well i mean but the song let's go
brandon again in the top charts in in
many different platforms which shows you
the popularity of people saying hey i i
you know this symbolic reference of
let's go brandon showing people's
discontent at the current administration
for what is obviously creating these
problems for everyone which will only be
exacerbated from here but you know
there's so many people and and they
don't want you to know that there's a
lot of these people you're finding out
about them through people making fun of
them but there's a lot more of them than
the mainstream media than social media
even lets on one of the one of the posts
seattle cops and firefighters feed
homeless after getting fired for
refusing vaccine and i saw that story i
see it here and i'm like
heroes seriously still to this day wow
and the comments the top comment oh so
now the seattle cops give a crap about
the homeless i'm sure they always did
yes these people think that like cops
are like vampires or something like evil
monsters
well that's their narrative that was
sold to them on big tech social media
all cops are evil they're all bad and
wait here we go third comment wow it's a
good thing there were reporters there to
capture the selfless act probably a
lucky coincidence are you suggesting
that fox news colludes with police in
some sort of propaganda scheme
i will tell you exactly what happened
i'm willing to bet that some
firefighters and police
reached out to someone a reporter and
said we just want to let you know we're
going to be out feeding the homeless
it's going to be like a protest kind of
like an action and they went cool we'll
send someone down yeah this happens all
the time very shady yeah very shitty
there's even there's a conspiracy entire
restaurants uh there's one in california
where the owner said that only if you're
unvaccinated you're allowed if you're
vaccinated you're not allowed into his
private restaurant in california and
that made a lot of news headlines so so
there's people even flipping it on that
level saying well if you were
discriminating against people's medical
choices i could do it as well i don't
believe in a kind of dude yeah i was in
california recently i i've experienced
that multiple places i mean the second
that i left the south that's where i
lived the second i got on the plane
there's been just nothing but problems
inconsistencies in the rules and it's
all coming from the top i mean i was i
was basically banned from coming out
here thank god i made it on the plane
but i mean i don't know if you guys want
to get into that we'll get into in a
second yeah sure we got another story
though i'm just i'm just i want to give
people that beacon of hope right 230
healthcare workers let go at rwj
barnabas virtua health for refusing
covid vaccine i mean this subreddit is a
plethora of people standing up for
themselves got placed on a suspension
from the school board because he refuses
to get the vaccine or get tested vaccine
bad 94 unvaccinated staff at yale new
haven health lose their jobs listen
i got no problem if you all want to go
to the doctor and you're concerned your
doctor says get the vaccine you say you
got it that's awesome that's that's
exactly what it's all about you and your
doctor and maybe maybe you got a bad
doctor you get a better one maybe you
get a good doctor maybe you got a doctor
like joe rogan got you talk to them you
say what's right here's my here's my
info they look at your history
when the government says if you want to
eat food if you want a job you've got to
abide by these rules that is new we've
never done anything like that that's
insane there's also websites popping up
showing
job boards for the unvaccinated that are
increasing in popularity with a lot of
people going on them and using them and
able to find employment when they were
just fired and lost a lot of their money
cool that's awesome yeah i feel like a
mainstream media really kind of gets off
on dividing conservatives and people who
don't think exactly like they do and i
think that this really is like tim said
a huge white pill because realizing that
you're not alone is incredibly powerful
like to see how many people are being
fired from health care places people who
work with vaccines nurses and doctors
saying no i'm not interested i don't
really want anything to do with that
that's kind of a white pill in itself
because then you're like okay i'm not
crazy maybe there's actually something
yeah isn't it funny how how everybody
was worshiping the nurses and all the
front line workers and that now we're
going to fire you now i thought we
needed i thought we were had a shortage
right what happened yeah well they work
with fear and intimidation and a lot of
the times a lot of these nurses aren't
even fired a lot of the front line
workers aren't even fired they're just
threatened and intimidated to a point
where they have to be
manipulated to get the shot some people
acquiesce some people do get the shot
but the people who stand up in some
cases do get to keep their jobs and the
mandates aren't implemented because
enough people did stand up to them looks
like there's about to be a bunch of
openings in baltimore baltimore police
union tells officers to not reveal
vaccine status
that's interesting too because that's
not telling them not to get it that
means even if they did get it they could
still be in defiance of the mandate and
i'll tell you if there's one city that
needs police it's probably baltimore so
while these people are laughing and
cheering us on and mocking these cops
it's going to be a different story when
like they're walking home and someone
robs them and they're like i don't
understand why crime is going up
i forgot the name of the police chief
but there's a big police district
outside of chicago and they open they
recently said that they're going to be
hiring all the police officers that get
fired in chicago and that they want to
welcome all of them to their
new jobs just you know a few miles away
from chicago so there's a lot of people
actively standing up actively speaking
up actively organizing and helping each
other out and that part of the story
isn't really
told
you know but i'm happy we're able to at
least talk about it here yeah that's
right luke truer words have never been
spoken
do people still want to defund the
police or is that just oh yeah yeah they
still want to do that maybe so they
didn't see what happened in seattle when
they gave people
oh they liked that i mean in seattle
they they straight up murdered a couple
kids so they they like that they
unloaded guns into a suv killing two
kids
who unloaded two black uh teenagers uh
adolescents that were shot and killed
uh it was this chas security saw a white
suv and were told that it was a white
supremacist so they saw it and they just
got down and they just
they said it was several hundred rounds
over ten minutes and i think the kids
were like 13 or 14 years old i don't
remember it i don't remember exactly so
someone would have to fact check me but
they were very young children
and then what happened was the antifa
people immediately rushed the vehicle
and stripped all the evidence out yep
yep and then the police weren't able to
come in and the emts weren't able to
come in and then they got a suit over it
yeah they got sued for not going in
amazing
you